thomas après le couac du début d'année
le congé devrait être porté à quinze
jours mais pour en arriver là ça a été
plutôt mouvementée un oui le 30 janvier
dernier la majorité et le gouvernement
s'était opposé à l'allongement de ce
congé de deuil pour enfants un refus qui
avait provoqué de vives réactions à
l'époque réaction de l'opposition du
medef aussi et surtout des manuels
macron le chef de l'état avait demandé
au gouvernement de faire preuve
d'humanité sur ce sujet alors si le
texte avait été refusée c'est davantage
par des réflexes politiciens que par une
véritable opposition sur le fond il faut
dire que cette proposition de loi et
n'émane pas d'un député de la majorité à
lehman de guy bricout qui est député udi
du nord nous avons pu le rencontrer avec
cynthia lauvergeon je propose de
l'écouter
j'ai même fait décorer côté de moi et je
disais même pénicaud attention je pense
que vous allez avoir des problèmes je ce
sens vous allez voir les problèmes parce
que je me répète j'étais en contact
d'associations qui attendaient beaucoup
de cette proposition de loi
je pense que peut-être la majorité n'a
pas voulu voter favorablement parce que
c'était dans le cadre des niches et
qu'on avait déjà eu plusieurs niches
d'accepter donc sera peut-être fait
comptablement trop de deux propositions
de loi pour nous
rappelé à l'ordre par le chef de l'état
la majorité devrait donc voté le texte
ce mardi un texte qui a été enrichi par
des amendements du sénat et qui passe
donc de 5 à 15 jours la durée de ce
congé de deuil une allocation
forfaitaire pour les familles
endeuillées serait également mise en
place et puis il faut noter que seront
considérés comme des enfants dans le
cadre de cette loi en tout cas les
enfants allant jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ans
je propose d'écouter à nouveau guy
bricout qui nous parle de la fierté
qu'il a de porter ce projet de loi c'est
encore une fois micro ct à l'auberge je
suis en contact pratiquement permanent
avec les associations qui s'occupent des
parents endeuillés des parents qui
perdent un enfant en bas âge ou en
dessous de 25 ans emma loi c'était de
faire en sorte que l'on tienne compte de
la détresse de ses parents et puis qu'on
allonge le congé de deuil pour permettre
aux parents de reprendre leur souffle
d'envisager l'avenir un peu plus
sereinement
c'est tout ça qui me fait décider j'ai
eu un grand écho on on est entouré de
beaucoup d'associations qui sont à mon
avis très attentive ce qui va se passer
de tout à l'heure voilà donc cette loi
qui aura mis du temps à être mise en
place a fait de nombreuses années que de
projets similaires sont portés par des
députés il devrait enfin être mises en
place donc après l'adoption à venir par
les députés de l'assemblée nationale
merci thomas bonnin en direct donc du
palais bourbon à paris